that's without good evening again good
morning brother bharata if we can see
clearly seconds result of flincher Allen
and decide constituency declaration of
results of whole family I can reveal
continuous election of a member of
parliament for the Allen and decide
constituency something looks a little
like Carly like one identically I call
in Everett's being the acting returning
officer at the above election to hereby
give notice that the number the folks
recorded for each candidate at the says
election is as follows
IRA we call in evidence service about
company I'd like myself I'm going to
probably added co2 joy him and that's
done money well it's a big shiny problem
this folio come on I like Emily Griffith
David Philip you Kip Wales one one one
seven 1117 you need sighs give me your
incomes in decoupage Hearst
Jacqueline arm applied come read the
party of Wales one one seven one
1171 you mean can siphon nightly Laura
Welsh Conservative Party candidate NBC's
tiger blood uncommon one eight zero
eight zero eighteen thousand and eighty
votes Ian's always been wasting in
degrees me of ugly sake
Tommy mark Richard Welsh Labour a big
company two three three one five twenty
three thousand yeah
[Applause]
Williams Peter Rai Welsh Liberal
Democrats three one zero seven seven
1077 votes in doing science i media a
scientific search the number of ballot
papers rejected was as follows
and I develop a pen a pretty shot on
fugly I like Emily
once you've an official mark zero
absolutely know what signal health in
voting for the when candidates seventeen
says we shall just phone again invasive
in excite writing or mark by which the
photo could be identified for SP many a
thing old again you know that father
plainly short peddler being at large or
holy 563 have you know curate hostel on
every Saharan antiquated chief
Tocqueville eighty-four cancel with me
Edward and I do hereby declare that Mark
Rocha Tommy has been duly elected
service member of parliament for the
Allen and decide
[Applause]
so congratulations and innovations the
respective candidates if we could invite
you to comes it's a few words beginning
with Marcus a successful candidate thank
you very much can I thank the returning
officer can I thank everyone who's
worked very hard counting tonight all
the other staff in the leisure center
for providing tea and coffee which is
kept us kept us going can I thank my
agent Dave Evans for the hard work that
he's put in how I thank all the labor
members who have worked so hard for me
and I appreciate it so much
and can I above all thank the people of
element D side for placing their trust
in me once more and can I thank my
fellow candidates for the campaign that
they have fought and can I thank my wife
Sally and my children Max and Oscar for
putting up with me over this campaign we
started this campaign when I think the
bookmakers I don't bet myself but the
bookmakers said we were something like 5
to 1 against now maybe we could have
given up at that point but we didn't we
went out there and we did what we do
which is to campaign which is to speak
to people which is to explain what we
have done and what we intend to do for
them
and once again can I thank the people of
Allen and each side because it is them
who decides who represent them not to
reason a it is then and can I thank them
again thank you
you